raise your hand if you've ever seen
someone give a great toast all right
keep your hand up if you wish you could
give that great a toast I remember the
first time I had that feeling I was
standing next to my dad I was 10 years
old he was 40 and it was his 40th
birthday party and all of a sudden
nobody turned to go look at my uncle who
was taking the stage to give a toast and
he told a story about when he and my dad
went fishing his little kids and he said
that they were bringing fish into the
boat and each time a fish came in my dad
would play with him and say that fish is
a family that fish has a life you we
have to throw that fish back and he
close by saying that that exemplified
the kind of guy my dad is somebody who
cares about family cares about others
and wants to do the right thing
everybody applauded my dad cried like a
baby which we do in my family and and it
made a memory for me that has lasted
until now it's one most powerful
memories for my childhood and all of us
here have the opportunity to give
powerful toast in tributes especially a
GSB we're gonna have a lot of
opportunities to do this in personal
settings we'll be asked to give toasts
at weddings and at birthday parties and
maybe at Thanksgiving dinner in
professional settings to will be asked
to give to us in many countries it's
expected that you give a toast to open a
new business toaster also a great way to
celebrate a deal that you've closed or
to thank a colleague who's done a really
good job they're also a good opportunity
to stand out as individuals giving a
toast is a good way to show that you
know how to take command of a room that
you're confident and that you appreciate
those around all the potential in toasts
can also make them an intimidating thing
to give fortunately there are rules that
you can follow you ensure that you give
a good toast and there's soup and so our
goal today is to give you the confidence
and skills that you need to give
powerful and impactful toasts in order
to really understand
what makes a toast powerful and
impactful we looked at a wide range of
different resources to really get at
five key elements of what makes a toast
truly memorable we looked at a varied
set of resources including Peggy Noonan
who is the former President Reagan's
chief speechwriter a writer of The
Simpsons rope losev Nick and other
resources as well and so we really came
down to five key elements of what makes
a toast really memorable the first one
is to be personal and sincere there's a
reason why Johnny remembered the speech
that his uncle gave that reason has to
do with the fact that his uncle conveyed
a personal authentic story there's also
a reason why you're in a person who's
standing at in front of other people
giving a toast that reason it has to do
with the fact that you have a close and
personal connection with the audience
and you have a close and personal
connection with a person you're talking
about use that to your advantage so be
personal secondly as you all know when
you stand up to give a speech in
particular a toast you feel a strong
emotion towards the audience you feel
you look at the people that you both
like and respect research as that you
use that emotion to convey heartfelt of
anticipate so remember to give an
memorable toast be personal and be
sincere the second learning that we'd
like you to take away is that you should
make it about them not you remember that
aim of your talk is to pay tribute to
the person that you're making the toast
to not to yourself I remember when I
made CEO at 42 mark was right there to
celebrate with me so let's raise a glass
to mark
recognize that was necessarily tributes
to mark make sure you're not Johnny when
you're giving a speech so pay tribute to
the person that you're actually meant to
pay tributes to third use humour
appropriately many people feel like they
need to start a toast with a joke
but the truth is it's far more important
to be authentic and oneself so if it's
not you don't force yourself to package
up on the other hand if you're a person
for whom humor is very natural
remember embarrassing isn't funny so
this trip to Vegas which was amazing at
the time at this point might not be an
appropriate thing to recall so leave it
out for tell a story every story has a
beginning middle and an end
and so every speech should have a
beginning middle and an end when you
walk into the room and you realize that
more than half of the audience doesn't
know you start with a brief introduction
of yourself your relationship to the
person or people you're toasting to and
offer a brief remark about the ceremony
you're all attempting and then take your
audience on a journey so that when you
come to an end they all feel like they
understood something that couple was
really meant to be together that company
is the best company to work for the
leader who's retiring today has been the
most inspiring leader in the history of
this firm and last but not least prepare
and practice
we all know very well by now that
there's no good speech without
preparation and the shorter the
presentation the longer the preparation
while there's no hard rules about how
long the toast should take the rule of
thumb says it should be 5 minutes or
less so start with a piece of blank
piece of paper write down your main
message that you want to convey and
recall some of the anecdotes and stories
and then use techniques that we've all
learned in this class to turn them into
this powerful story that you're soon to
tell once you're done outlining your
speech practice and rehearse rehearsing
will help you feel a lot more
comfortable with the content you're
about to say and hopefully we'll free
you up to make contact with your
audience make an eye contact with the
person you're talking to or with the
people you're giving a toast to so to
wrap it up today our hope is that the
next time you're asked to give a speech
to give a toast you will embrace the
challenge and remember about five things
impersonal and sincere make it about
them not you use humor appropriately
tell story practice prepare and practice
when I walked into this class nine weeks
ago I wasn't quite sure what to expect
all that I knew is that our classmates
had highly recommended the class and the
teaching team but that was about it and
over the past two months I've been
really impressed by how much everyone's
grown as speakers and as writers
we've learned how to clearly structure
presentations we've learned how to write
impactful memos we've learned how to
really connect with the audience through
personal stories and I contact Nick when
you did your first presentation it was
really impactful not only was your story
of brawny really moving but the way you
delivered it was inspiring to me and all
of your presentations this court have
have been really great so I use you as a
source of motivation I'm getting ready
to speak so thank you and Luis see up
there you have incredible ability to
connect with the audience your you have
such a conversational style that is
impressive and it's something I think
about before I even come on and I use
you as a source of inspiration and Zach
ta we've we've gotten to know you a lot
better this quarter and I think we're
we're all impressed that Jesse is still
your wife
as we as we wrap up the class and as
some of us get ready to graduate we're
here today better presenters better
communicators and better leaders now the
journey isn't done well for plenty of
opportunities to speak in public in the
future but there be giving a speech at a
conference whether it be giving a
startup pitch on Sand Hill Road whether
it be those brief everyday moments when
you'll have a chance to stand up and
make a memorable tribute now you'll have
a glass of champagne or sprite in front
of you so sprays a glass - 3:15 seize
those moments where you can stand up and
make a memorable tribute whether it be -
thanks somebody in the audience whether
it be to thank your guests for coming to
your housewarming or whether it be to
give a birthday toast your family will
remember for years to come cheer chairs